Please welcome the talented, beautiful
and inspiring Idina Menzel.
(audience cheering and clapping loudly)
Hi. Hi Drew. Can the ladies organize
my clutter and my kitchen?
That's what I needed to take away from this.
In addition to meeting you.
My whole thing is "What do you do with someone like me?
Who's always just been a slob."
Well, you can't do it all.
Like maybe you need a junk drawer so you can go out
and do what you do that freaks out everybody on the planet.
Because I think that you've been such an amazing role model
to girls and women. - Oh, thank you.
And you're such an icon.
How do you like...
Does that pressuresome to be like...?
Yeah, it does.
I imagine.
I think it's one of those things that's like
the most beautiful gift and sometimes a curse
because I thank my lucky stars every day
that I am associated with some of these wonderful roles
and young women that have these incredible
empowering messages and that I get to be on a stage
when we're not in a pandemic
and sing to a sea of young girls in blue dresses.
On the other hand, I'm a woman in her forties.
I'm a mess. My kitchen is a pig stye.
I feel like a failure.
And it's like, you've chosen me to lift up
your young little girls and boys. I don't know.
And so I contend with that a lot.
I'm just feeling like a hypocrite.
And then I figure if I just put it out there
and I'm authentic about it,
at least you won't...
I fake it till I make it that's all I can say.
Well ironically,
(crowd chuckles)
as a mom, I always saw also so many girls
gravitate towards Elsa and I was like,
"Oh, the complicated one. Interesting."
And what was so great is that the love story
was between sisters.
Like, Oh my gosh-
I know.
I hadn't really seen that before.
And I have a younger sister, three years younger than me.
I actually brought her to the Oscars my first time
when I was singing, Let It Go with the Oscars.
And I brought my sister and my sister is one of these women
that I, this month and every day of our lives,
look up to and honor.
And I brought her from Boulder, Colorado.
Her and her husband relocated for the pandemic.
We rented a house nearby that has a little pool
and a little pool house that we converted to a school house.
And she does a pod, 'cause she's a fifth grade teacher
and my son is in fifth grade.
So it's my son and three other kids.
Well, as schools have been tasked to think differently.
Parents have been tasked to have to do differently.
And I did homeschool before I started this job
for six months and I think I lost 10 years of my life.
I know.
I've never-
Because you overhear what they're supposed to hand in.
But it was like, "Did you do this, honey?
Did you do this?"
He's like, "Get off my back Mom, I want space."
But then I wanna make sure he's being a good student
and he's not gonna miss everything.
And it's just...
And he also did, the kids start to figure out
that they can put these virtual backgrounds on,
or I'm not gonna tell you who,
but one of his friends had took a couple shots of himself,
he's so resourceful, in different positions
like this, like this, whatever.
And then he would walk away from this screen.
No.
And then flash
different shots so it looked like he was still live
and switching positions.
(crowd laughs)
That's so Ferris Bueller genius.
Like when he would put
the mannequin in the bed-
Exactly.
with like the snoring sounds.
I've never felt,
I've never felt honestly, as a self-loathing challenged.
It has been the hardest, most incredible year
which is why teachers have never been more appreciated
or in the heroic forefront.
No, I'm totally with you.
And if you do wanna see a mom in being delirious
over pandemic, check out this little kid show that...
I went up into my son's tree house
that he never even goes in and I had to go up there
to film myself for something.
And I started singing to my camera and reading a story
and decided I wanted to be the next Mrs. Rogers.
But if you wanna check it out
we're gonna have a second episode coming out soon.
And hopefully people can watch with their little kids
and also have an escape and put them in front of the iPad
with something, somewhat quality.
And if you go to our show website
at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com we'll have a feature on it
and a link right to it as well.
Thank you.
And the I am Every Woman Campaign, this is so important.
Women's history month.
Will you please tell us about this campaign
and why it's important to you.
Yes, it's this age old organization called CARE
that did the CARE package.
That's where that name comes from.
And they go around the world uplifting women
and young girls out of poverty.
That's what they do and so they teamed up
with international Women's day
to do this campaign this year.
And then I got to go in the studio
with one of my all-time idols.
I used to sing at weddings and bar mitzvahs
before I got my big break and I would sing Through The Fire.
I do know that song.
Chaka Khan was a hero of mine.
She's one of the greatest singers of all time.
And I was in the studio with her.
With Drew and Chaka Khan. Come on.
That's so exciting. Chaka Khan.
Oh my gosh.
She's incredible.
She's a goddess.
Well thank you
doing that.
The history of the CARE package, Idina, Chaka Khan
and women's history month is one of the most
potent combinations I've ever heard of.
Idina Menzel I'm so excited to make your acquaintance
And you too. I really am.
Thank you for having me. I'm honored to be on your show.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
(crowd applause)
(lively music)